Bulgaria con unos 7 millones de
habitantes y situado junto a las costas
del mar Negro en el sudeste de Europa es
uno de esos países que siempre están en
medio de algún que otro lío y en el que
nunca sabes por dónde demonios pueden
terminar saliendo las cosas para que os
hagáis una idea hablamos de un país que
en el terreno político es un Monumental
caos en 2023 van a celebrar sus quintas
elecciones parlamentarias en apenas dos
años Sí sí habéis escuchado bien 5
años esto deja a Italia a Japón o
incluso a Israel prácticamente como unos
aprendices en este particular arte del
caos político Claro que eso no es todo
puede que te sorprenda pero Bulgaria
también tiene un tremendo cacao a la
hora de conciliar sus relaciones con
occidente y con Rusia
a nivel de calle y justo antes de la
invasión rusa de Ucrania que empezó el
24 de febrero del 2022 los búlgaros
tenían una opinión estupenda del
dictador ruso Vladimir Putin No importa
que yo hubiera invadido a crimea en 2014
o que sea un sátrapa habituado a violar
los Derechos Humanos más elementales
concretamente el 70% de los búlgaros
tenía una opinión favorable de Putin en
2021 y el 45% consideraban a Rusia como
un importante socio estratégico
[Música]
y claro esto no resulta particularmente
curioso cuando nos damos cuenta de que
Bulgaria es un país que forma parte de
la Unión Europea desde el 2007 y de la
otan desde el año 2004 es decir Unión
Europea y otan a priori cualquiera puede
decir que Bulgaria está completamente
integrada en el bando occidental frente
a la órbita de influencia rusa sin
embargo como veis la realidad es mucho
más compleja y precisamente la guerra en
Ucrania y la actuación de Sofía del
gobierno búlgaro me refiero es una buena
oportunidad para intentar entender esta
aparente contradicción así que sin más
preámbulo arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bulgaria no solo es según los propios
informes de Bruselas el país más pobre y
corrupto de toda la Unión Europea sino
que también es probablemente el más Pro
ruso a nivel de calle de toda la unión
Con permiso de Hungría Claro está
digamos que en función de las
circunstancias sofías inclina más hacia
Bruselas o hacia Moscú O al menos así ha
sido hasta hace poco tiempo es por eso
que muchos analistas de política
internacional consideran que este país
es una especie de talón de Aquiles de la
Unión Europea o un caballo de Troya para
la otan por seguir aludiendo a la
mitología de la antigua Grecia vaya y la
pregunta que todos podemos hacernos es
como demonios es esto posible no se
supone que han contribuido a rescatar a
Ucrania como diantres encaja eso con
toda esta historia Pues bien Lo vamos a
ver pero antes antes tenemos que ver De
dónde narices procede esa especie de
filia por Rusia fijaos
el hecho de que tantos búlgaros tengan
una visión favorable de Rusia o al menos
la tuvieran hasta el 2022 tiene
lógicamente sus razones y quizás una de
las que más peso tiene es
paradójicamente una de carácter
histórico Y es que veréis vulgaria es un
país con cierta historia compartida con
Rusia por ejemplo podemos remontarnos
hasta la segunda mitad del siglo XIX
cuando el emperador ruso Alejandro II
fue clave para liberar a la nación
búlgara del imperio otomano eso permitió
más tarde la creación de un estado
búlgaro independiente debido a eso las
relaciones entre Bulgaria y Rusia no
Solo han sido históricamente buenas sino
que durante mucho tiempo se cultivó una
visión favorable que llegaba a pintar a
Rusia como un país libertador y de hecho
Sofía incluso quiso unirse a la unión
soviética Y aunque finalmente eso nunca
sucedió en la práctica funcionó como la
decimosexta repúblicas socialistas
soviética
Y sí vale Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos a ver Alberto realmente es tan
importante algo que pasó en el del siglo
19 para definir las relaciones
internacionales en pleno 2023 pues lo
cierto Es que en este caso podemos decir
que sí de hecho la visión que los
búlgaros han tenido tradicionalmente de
Rusia se ve claramente reflejada en la
política doméstica
para que os hagáis una idea de los 28
partidos y coaliciones que se
presentaron a las elecciones de octubre
del 2022 unos 15 eran abiertamente
procremlin Y aunque la enorme
fragmentación política que se da en este
país favorece que la mayoría de esos
partidos no alcancen el umbral mínimo de
representación del 4% de los votos si
los juntamos a todos el resultado es que
aproximadamente uno de cada cuatro o
cinco búlgaros vota por opciones
claramente rusófilas lo que
comprensiblemente ha tenido una
importante influencia en lo que respecta
a la reacción del gobierno respecto a la
invasión rusa Bueno al menos en lo que
concierne a la reacción oficial
[Música]
4 de marzo del 2022 si bien Sofía está
proporcionando asistencia humanitaria
Bulgaria no está enviando armas estamos
demasiado cerca del conflicto como para
poder hacer eso dijo petcop pero Y si os
dijéramos que esto era lo que se pensaba
hasta hace relativamente poco pero que
con el tiempo se ha demostrado que no
era más que una especie de mentira para
no soliviantar la política nacional y si
resulta que el ex Primer Ministro
búlgaro kiril petcoff decía una cosa y
hacía justo la contraria incluso Aunque
eso implicara ocultarles La verdad a
miembros de su propio gobierno de
coalición Pues sí tal cual como lo
escucháis eso es exactamente lo que
ocurrió al comienzo de la invasión
petcoff jugó un papel clave para
rescatar a Ucrania y eso es algo que se
ha sabido recientemente gracias a una
investigación publicada por el diario
alemán belt la cuestión es que hizo
exactamente Bulgaria al principio de la
invasión y Qué consecuencias tuvo para
el país y para el gobierno de petcoff
Pues bien ya os adelanto que toda esta
historia es interesante atentos
[Música]
el hombre que mintió por Ucrania
la invasión rusa de Ucrania hizo
estallar por los aires las más o menos
equilibradas relaciones entre Rusia y
los países de Europa del este y por
supuesto Bulgaria un país bastante
prorruso se encontró de repente en una
encrucijada Y es que veréis Bulgaria ha
sido tradicionalmente un país muy
independiente de Rusia sobre todo en lo
que respecta a los suministros
energéticos Ni más ni menos que el 95%
de los 3.000 millones de metros cúbicos
de gas que cada año consume el país era
un suministrados por Rusia y con el
petróleo ocurría tres cuartas partes de
lo mismo al comienzo de la Guerra el 60%
del crudo consumido por los búlgaros
procedía de Rusia y era refinado en una
planta que educó él tiene en burgas una
ciudad situada en la costa búlgara del
mar Negro Sin embargo a pesar de esta
situación tan comprometida y de los
problemas políticos que le podía
ocasionar petcoff no se quedó parado y
consiguió que su país se convirtiera en
el primero de la Unión Europea en cortar
por completo las importaciones gas ruso
algo que sin embargo hasta ahora no ha
podido hacer con el petróleo Bulgaria
exenta del embargo petrolero a Rusia
hasta finales del 2024 pero esperad un
momento porque lo importante de esta
historia no es lo que ya sabíamos sino
lo que no sabíamos
[Música]
en parte aprovechando esta exención el
gobierno búlgaro o mejor dicho petcoff y
sus ministros de confianza aprovecharon
para convertir a su país en un puente de
suministro de diesel a Ucrania
especialmente al principio del conflicto
diesel que sería utilizado sobre todo
para suministrar a los vehículos de
combate lo hicieron precisamente
atendiendo una petición expresa del
gobierno ucraniano a las autoridades
búlgaras Pero la pregunta que muchos os
podéis estar haciendo es a ver a ver si
la refinería que hay en bulgarias de
lucoil que es una gran petrolera rusa
como diantres podían hacer para que los
rusos exportasen diesel al país al que
le habían declarado la guerra
Pues bien al parecer para conseguirlos
se fragó una gran operación de engaño
muchos de los trabajadores de la propia
refinería de lucoy en Bulgaria siendo
contrarios a la guerra accedieron a
atender la petición del gobierno de su
país concretamente Bulgaria necesita
para su consumo doméstico
aproximadamente el 50% de la producción
de diésel de esta refinería Pues bien el
excedente fue a parar casi en exclusiva
a Ucrania hablamos de un volumen
exportado a Ucrania entre enero y
noviembre del 2022 de unos 700 millones
de euros en combustible mil veces más
que en 2021
[Música]
esto se hizo sin que prácticamente nadie
lo supiera y paradójicamente se hizo con
petróleo ruso Sí sí tal cual lo habéis
escuchado con petróleo ruso el diesel
que estaba entrando a Ucrania a través
de Bulgaria procedía de petróleo
importado desde Rusia refinado por
lukoil y luego enviado al país vecino a
través de Rumanía en trenes y camiones
cisterna para abastecer la maquinaria de
guerra ucraniana en total Bulgaria ha
llegado a cubrir con este sorprendente
método hasta el 40% de todo el diésel
que necesitaba Ucrania es decir que sin
esta treta el gobierno de zelensky
hubiera tenido muchos problemas para
resistir la embestida rusa
Pero eso no es todo quizás la parte más
interesante de la mentirijilla de petcop
está en eso de que vulgaría no está
enviando armas Pues bien Ahora sabemos
que esto tampoco fue del todo cierto se
ha sabido que al principio de la
invasión Bulgaria Le entregó a Ucrania
numerosas rondas de municiones para su
artillería digamos que se aprovecharon
de que el ejército búlgaro está equipado
mayoritariamente con equipos soviéticos
concretamente el gobierno de petcoff
maniobró para entregar a Ucrania grandes
cantidades de munición para los
lanzacohetes múltiplesnianos a través de
terceras empresas radicadas en países
como Polonia o República Checa hay quien
no considerará que estos son armas pero
lo cierto es que lo miremos por donde lo
miremos entregar municiones supone
entregar armamento con lo que sí kiril
petcoff también mintió en esto y lo hizo
para ayudar a Ucrania
lo que no está tan claro es hasta qué
punto consiguió realmente hacerlo en
secreto Ya que en abril del 2022 nos
encontramos con esta noticia la Rusia
Gastón suspende el suministro apolonio y
Bulgaria casualidad ni idea no podemos
saber si la reacción de la rusa gazprom
está relacionada directamente con la
ayuda búlgara a Ucrania pero como poco
llama la atención en cualquier caso lo
sorprendente de toda esta historia es
como el gobierno búlgaro o al menos
parte del gobierno maniobró para ayudar
a Ucrania a escondidas para entregarles
a los ucranianos toneladas de munición y
de petróleo Ruso y claro La pregunta es
Además del miedo a quedarse sin
suministros energéticos que otro motivo
podía tener petcop para ayudar con tanto
secretismo en ese momento Pues suena
raro eso de que un país de la mismísima
otan tenga que maniobrar prácticamente
en secreto cuando muchos otros lo
estaban haciendo azon quitado pues bien
veámoslo
un país Atrapado en el desastre
como ya os hemos contado el comienzo de
este vídeo la situación política de
Bulgaria no atraviesa su mejor momento
gobiernos bloqueados elecciones cada
pocos meses coaliciones de gobierno
inoperantes la cosa en Sofía está tan
tensa que cualquier paso en falso que
pueda enfadar a unos socios de gobierno
podría acabar con el gabinete saltando
por los aires y con la convocatoria de
unas nuevas elecciones un ejemplo de
todo esto es precisamente el gobierno de
kiril petcop que apenas duró poco más de
medio año de diciembre del 21 agosto del
22 sin embargo al contrario de lo que
muchos seguro estaréis imaginando el fin
de este gobierno no tuvo que ver
realmente con el tema de Ucrania sino
que se produjo por desavenencias en
torno a los presupuestos y por la
posición de Bulgaria en lo que respecta
a la adhesión de macedonia del Norte a
la Unión Europea ya os hemos dicho que
en este país si no es una cosa es otra
El caso es que en el momento de preparar
Este vídeo su Primer Ministro es gala
Donald
un señor que fue ministro en dos
gobiernos anteriores que se presentó
como independiente y que estará de paso
hasta las próximas elecciones de abril
del 23 pero no nos desviemos volviendo
al tema del secretismo y las mentiras de
petcoff hay un par de cosas que tenemos
que tener en cuenta la primera es que
kiril petcoff encabezaba un difícil
gobierno compuesto por los centristas
socioliberales conservadores Pro
occidente de una coalición de izquierdas
liderada por el partido socialista
búlgaro para los que no estéis al día en
política búlgara imagino que esa es la
inmensa mayoría el partido socialista
búlgaro es El Heredero directo del
partido comunista búlgaro y en los
últimos años ha ido transitando hacia
posiciones cada vez más ruso filas y
socialmente conservadoras un ejemplo
pues fijaos el partido socialista
búlgaro está en contra de la extensión
de las sanciones contra Rusia porque
dañan los intereses nacionales de
Bulgaria la economía búlgara la
agricultura el turismo cornelion Innova
líder del partido socialista de Bulgaria
en fin Si todos los países que tenía
tengo que perder con las sanciones
hubiesen pensado solo en su ombligo no
se habría llegado a ningún acuerdo y
Putin estaría la mar de contento El caso
es que tener a este partido con cuatro
ministerios en el gobierno no era el
mejor de los escenarios para ser duro
con Rusia ni liderar absolutamente nada
Pero por supuesto la situación de la
opinión a pie de calle tampoco ayudaba
precisamente mucho
[Música]
por lo general la clase política búlgara
al menos aquellos partidos grandes con
opciones a gobernar suelen ser
proccidentales así como también lo son
sus élites económicas aunque sólo sea
por la lluvia de millones de euros que
está cayendo en Bulgaria gracias a los
fondos de la Unión Europea fondos que se
han convertido en un tremendo balón de
oxígeno para los magnates locales
Sin embargo a nivel de la calle las
situaciones un tanto diferente buena
parte de la población consume con
frecuencia propaganda rusa y algunos
medios de comunicación están
directamente controlados por Moscú lo
que hace que Rusia siga teniendo un gran
poder de influencia sobre la opinión
pública de hecho según analistas y
organismos internacionales de toda
índole si hay un país donde las agencias
de propaganda rusas y las estrategias de
desinformación del kremlin campan a sus
anchas Ese es precisamente pulgarín la
guerra de información de Rusia se
expande por Europa del este en bulgaría
el kremlin pagó a periodistas analistas
políticos y otros ciudadanos influyentes
2.000 euros al mes para publicar
contenido Los investigadores también han
descu sofisticadas redes de cuentas
falsas Bots y trolls en una creciente
difusión de desinformación y propaganda
en el país en pasados vídeos ya os hemos
hablado del papel que juega la guerra de
la información en la guerra híbrida que
suele emplear Rusia en sus relaciones
internacionales
el resultado como podéis ver en pantalla
es que A mediados de junio de 2022 y ya
con la invasión rusa viene en marcha y
un montón de crímenes de guerra
perfectamente documentados apenas la
mitad de los búlgaros encuestados
culpaba a Rusia de la invasión a Ucrania
y lo que es peor más de uno de cada
cuatro consideraba que la culpa de lo
que estaba pasando era de occidente por
provocar a Rusia recordad que hablamos
de un país miembro de la otan y de la
Unión Europea evidentemente Es probable
que todo esto haya ido evolucionando con
el paso del tiempo y las atrocidades
rusas pero el problema está ahí y ayuda
a entender porque este país balancea en
un difícil equilibrio entre occidente y
Rusia de hecho el gobierno búlgaro
actual ha estado haciendo cosas raras
que puede que a muchos os cueste
entender cosas como esta 22 de noviembre
del 2022 vulgaria permitirá que una
refinería del mar Negro propiedad de una
compañía petrolera rusa sigue operando y
exportando productos petrolíferos a la
Unión Europea hasta finales de 2024 a
pesar de las advertencias de Bruselas
está en contra de las sanciones del
bloque el acuerdo entre Bulgaria y
lucoil de propiedad rusa dará un impulso
adicional de 350 millones de euros al
presupuesto de Bulgaria según
estimaciones del gobierno de Sofía es
decir que parece que Bulgaria quiere
aprovechar su particular exención sobre
las sanciones al petróleo ruso para
hacer negocio y meter petróleo ruso en
la Unión Europea sea como sea llegamos
hasta aquí la pregunta es para ti qué
pensáis de que el ex Primer Ministro
petcoff ayudóse a Ucrania en secreto son
países como Bulgaria Hungría aliados
confiables de La otan dejadnos vuestras
opiniones aquí abajo en los comentarios
y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante No olvides darle a like y
suscribiros a visualpolitik para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras novedades y
recordad que si queréis apoyarnos para
que podamos hacer cada vez más y mejor
contenido podéis hacerlo sumados a
nuestra comunidad en patreon os dejamos
el enlace también en la descripción una
vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]